President Trump is meeting resistance
this morning from some Senate
Republicans as he pushes his sweeping
tax plan the president called on
Congress to approve his overhaul at an
event yesterday in Pennsylvania he said
that his plan shrinks the number of tax
brackets from the current eight to four
but details including income levels for
the new brackets are still an unknown
major Garrett is at the White House with
the latest on this story major good
morning good morning the president
trades the praised rather long-haul
truckers in Pennsylvania and promised
that his tax cut still under
construction will give the average
American family about four thousand
dollars more per year sounds good but
that's the roughest of estimates and the
lack of detail has led outside analysts
like the International Monetary Fund to
question in the end whether these tax
cuts will generate economic growth or
boost wages all I can say is you better
get it passed as the president struggles
to get votes in the Senate for tax
reform his feud with senator bob Corker
isn't his only problem on Capitol Hill
the White House fears other Republican
senators may block mr. Trump's plan and
we're gonna fight and we're gonna get
those Republicans and maybe a few of
those Democrats to raise their hand and
you're gonna have so much money to spend
in this wonderful country the president
appeared confident but according to a
Vanity Fair story published Wednesday
mr. Trump told his former head of
security and close friend Keith Schiller
quote I hate everyone in the White House
there are a few exceptions but I hate
them the report also claims that chief
of staff John Kelly is miserable and his
job and remains only out of a sense of
duty
White House officials denied the
accounts and sources say the president's
mood is as unpredictable and volatile as
it always has been Kelly is also
described as secure in his job but
fatigued by the president's temper still
Kelly had enough clout to persuade the
president to nominate his deputy Kirsten
Nielsen as Secretary of Homeland
Security Kelly's previous post calm
before the storm you're not gonna talk
about that on Fox News the president
says that vague statement which provoked
days of speculation was about North
Korea
not saying I'm doing anything and I'm
not saying I'm not but we shouldn't be
talking about it that was the
president's 16th interview with Fox
since taking office he's given five to
other broadcast outlets and yesterday he
said that those broadcast news outlets
should have their licenses challenged or
possibly revoked that prompted Ben Sasse
Republican senator from Nebraska to
question on Twitter whether the
president was recounting his support for
the First Amendment Charlie thanks made
you